Kings trying to get Kevin fala going as far as
scoring only two goals in 15 games Talbot will
play it for Roy sends it up to Moore Let It Go
to Center here's Deno with fiala Deno to fiala
in ch [Applause] SC a minute 20 into the game
Kevin fala starts the scoring way the kings
are able to break out there's the pitching
defenseman M up and he gets beat you got to
get the puckle man he doesn't get either and
then the two on one now you see the hands of
fala watch the quick move to the back and then
it quickly Elevate over the pad under the glove
the speed the quickness and the skill coming
right at you Kings lead one to nothing the
four lines and not a lot of discrepancy that's
how effective lat's line has been by field out
centers reaching for Kopitar I don't know if he
got a winds up down into Panthers ice lazat now
got it from Lewis gave it back to Lewis in the
middle Anderson whistles a drive wide from 50
fet they've struggled here on home ICE overall
18% off the draw to know for Spence a high shot
gloved down by Kings retrieve they're on the man
advantage [Applause] CV and now Spence to CV one
timer save loose Puck cleared away and over the
stick dowy will swing it around and now the Kings
to Center Ice fala for Anderson moves in his
pass in front do know denied and a [Applause]
stoppage November is hockey fights cancer month
as a shot from the blue line is handled balinskis
I mean it was against Carolina oh behind the net
lomor dishes it off and on the left wing a chance
handled by talbet as mikola Veri hands it off and
now they get it to barov power play Florida foret
Chuck in the middle a shot save rebound Veri can't
te it up and from his knees dubba to CV who dumps
it high in the air knocked down in the neutral
zone dubba Over the Line to Anderson Dolan man
in front he centers shot C save his made oh
a great look gets the Zone here watch in the
middle he'll get the Zone but very quickly off to
the side the breakdown look at both defensemen of
the Panthers come across and you're not going to
get a better chance than that with CV you see the
misplay kulakov comes across you already have
one guy over pick a corner on babski the Allen
the Kings win the draw Roy for more for Deno up
high Roy a shot gloved B rovski Reinhardt threw
it in the middle barov was tied up now Veri out
to the Blue Line shot balinskis is on Save made
by talvin so the Panthers earlier watch his
counter hit there by Trevor Moore they uh saw
something in those three players that have really
helped them build a good team in on right wing
Rodriguez a chance save made and we're expected
to be back soon as next game BOS ran a shot block
gets it back feeds the middle backhander Rodriguez
kicked out they both fall off balance Anderson
a play for Byfield Byfield back to Anderson
with a shot save is made with kempe in front
front Panther's almost turned it over tiala lobs
it down the ice it's on side shot sounded like
it hit the vagi on a shoot in Panthers were
offside they'll have to touch up they do and
here's kempe on a shoot in glove down by barosi
and he will hold on well earlier in this period
ran heart camped in front of the goal might
have got a touch on it barov the left Circle
cause high speed and another pass through the
goal mouth by kachuck cev turning had a great
chance in the first period over skated the puck
lomor away with it lombo driving wide on Anderson
but a good stick by Anderson Kings everyone the
NHL working together to make it happen and car
will have more on Kevin fala and what he's done
scramble in front of bosi the puck winds up in on
the goal tender who's able to Reinhardt a pass
tipped out the center here's room for Kopitar
moves in a shot handled by bosski kopar kind of
had to rush that shot as a panther was closing
in on him and kopar again with it plays it up
the wall Kee chases feeds the middle tried to
get it to fiala but that was broken up and
now fiala right up the middle a shot stick
save leaves it on the left wing board spala
for denan out up top dowy winds a shot stick
save oh Bowski just saw that steered in
by a Florida stick turned over by tbut
but Lindell I don't know if he was shooting
her passing up high it comes and a drive Dy
by Kee across to KOB shot pass Byfield save
rebound loose fala in tight save fala again
save made Reinhardt got it out of the zone
no change yet though for the Panthers they
didn't get down the ice here's kobitar
handing it off toala to kopar one timer
score two nothing la really be creative here
fella this pass is absolutely perfect power
play down to 40 seconds left barov their Captain
for Reinhardt in front to emman Lon a chance save
scramble and the puck cleared away value yeah
he and eckan Larson look out big hit to Chuck
on More Kings with it Den know feeds it across
right side shot pass tipped save more shoots
blocked one of the Panthers got upended by dubba
no call here is barov nice move and on goal shoots
blocker save oh tet standing his ground again
Panthers feed the middle shot score Reinhardt
after one big save they got another good look
it's a one-goal game and I think the Kings have
missed managed this period so far think possession
think take time off the clock think reset you'll
see the shot the movement it's back to five
on five and just coming across to meet the
pass and then also to release quickly and of
course the most dangerous man on the team is
Sam Reinhardt I like the way he came across if
you're a panther he just held the puck he didn't
try to make a play that wasn't there he held the
puck the Kings get possession speeding in dub to
the net a backhander is stopped by babski and dub
what's going on in his body here he coming at you
tries to protect oh he hits his legs on the post
and it didn't move that post didn't move watch
here not here now watch bang boom did he hyper
extend maybe bosi Kings Battle to keep it in they
do brunstrom down to the circle a shot Glo down
loose knocked away from grundstrom and cleared to
Center Carl grundstrom moving in for
a chance six goals for Carl Puck out
to the blue line now for hegi a shot
block puck back out to Ean Larson shot
block Kings with it will get a clear
and there's the end of the [Music]
game